pour les autres sans papiers évacués
hier de l'église saint-bernard les
procédures administratives et
judiciaires se sont poursuivies toute la
journée dans toute leur complexité
certains notamment les femmes et les
enfants ont été libérés dans la nuit du
centre de rétention de vincennes pour le
d'autres les auditions ont commencé au
palais de justice de paris l'une des
porte parole des sans papiers a été
condamné à deux mois de prison avec
sursis alors que le procureur avait
requis trois mois de prison ferme et
trois ans la direction de territoire le
point avec valérie fournier et gilles
marini scènes de vie quotidienne au
centre de rétention de vincennes des
immigrés arrive menotté mais difficile
aujourd'hui de savoir si parmi eux se
trouvaient les expulser de saint bernard
dans cette confusion qui a régné toute
la journée on repère tout d'un coup des
cars transportant des africains
destination inconnue en revanche au
palais de justice
quelques certitudes ce matin 34 100 pap
y ont vu leur garde à vue renouveler
dont les dix grévistes de la faim et au
sujet de deux d'entre eux leur avocate
est inquiète
ils ne sont plus à l'hôpital compte tenu
de la gravité de la situation et
prennent une mesure de mise en liberté
deux
salhab autre sujet de mécontentement des
âmes au coeur
il estime n'avoir pu rencontrer leur
client placé hier en rétention
administrative dans des conditions
normales ça ne peut pas voir chacun un
client du réveillon tous ensemble nous
n'avons pas pu pénétrer dans les box qui
sont habituellement réservé aux avocats
à 10 heures cet après midi une
soixantaine de personnes sont venues
soutenir 46 autres sans papiers qui
comparaissent actuellement devant le
tribunal de grande instance de paris
et pour les avocats c'est également la
confusion il nous manque un certain
nombre de sans papiers actuellement on
en a recensé un peu plus de 60
nécessairement y en ad'autres ailleurs
environ quinze autres sont papiers sont
actuellement devant la 23e chambre
correctionnelle
et parmi eux il y a à boubacar diop leur
porte parole le préfet est semble-t-il
retirerait sa requête sur la
prolongation rétention conséquence il
devrait être remis en liberté ce n'est
pas certain madigan fils et autres porte
parole des sans papiers est condamné à
deux mois de prison avec sursis
elle vient d'être remise en liberté
dernière certitude les 53 femmes et 64
enfants de l'église saint-bernard ont
été relâchés hier soir et déposer à leur
demande devant une station de métro
et selon lui